have you talked to Andre capathi or have
you talked to Elon about him anymore he
went to work at open AI what do you love
about Andre kopathy he and to me he's
one of the truly special humans we got
oh man like you know his streams are
just a level of quality so far beyond
mine like I can't help myself like it's
just it's just you know yeah he's good
he wants to teach you yeah I want to
show you that I'm smarter than you yeah
he has no that's I mean uh thank you for
the sort of the raw authentic honesty
yeah I mean a lot of us have that I
think Andre is as legit as he gets in
that he just wants to teach you and is
this a there's a curiosity that just
drives him and just like at his at the
stage where he is in life to be still
like one of the best tinkerers in the
world yeah it's crazy like to uh what is
it micrograd microgrid yeah inspiration
for tiny grad
is that the whole I mean his his
cs231n was this was this was the
inspiration this is what I just took and
ran with and ended up writing this so
you know but I mean to me that don't go
work for Darth Vader man I mean the flip
side to me is that the fact that he's
going there is a good sign
for open AI I think you know I I like
Alias discover a lot I like those those
guys are really good at what they do
yeah I know they are and that's kind of
what's even like more and you know what
it's not that open AI doesn't open
source the weights of gpd4
it's that they go in front of Congress
and that is what upsets me you know we
had two effective altruist Sams go in
front of Congress one's in jail
I think you're drawing parallels on
there